hello hello
welcome to the stream uh we're going to
be surfing
twitter today there's a lot of trending
topics so i want to get to these topics
um kellyanne conway is trending
and let's see what i thought howard
stern is trending for his
uh view on the vaccine
uh let's see let's see let's see what
else what else do we have trending
what else what else
uh i think hashtag
trump as a terrorist
is trending we're gonna get to that
oh
do oh hunter biden's laptop or hunter
biden is trending the new world order uh
sarah palin is now trending for what she
said about aoc uh katie porter is
trending for smashing
joe manchin without a whiteboard uh
there's a lot of stuff going on today so
i wanted to get on here and really kind
of talk about
uh
what's trending
what all this [ __ ] means and
you guys know i do a podcast every
wednesday three o'clock central four
o'clock eastern but i can't fit all the
topics in in one hour in one week so
we started to do this streaming thing
where we stream and we surf twitter
together so if you want to surf with me
uh we stream it on twitter and we also
stream it on twitch
so if you like to watch twitch
go over there follow me
download uh it's
thetonymichaels
or follow me on twitter at the tony
michaels you can
you can see the trend there at the top
let's let's show it
oh i gotta refresh here
there we go let's see come on there it
is so there's the stream right there at
the top of the page
and i think that's where we're going to
start we're just going to run down my
timeline because i've retweeted a lot of
stuff today about these trending topics
and then we'll move over we'll move over
to the explore tab
and see what's trending so let's start
the countdown let's start the countdown
and then we'll come back